THEY GET ONE MORE MEMBER ON THE
STATUS OF SUBCOMMITTEE.
PERFECT WE ARE GOING TO START
AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE I HAVE. A
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING.
THE FIRST ONE AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE. BY MR MERCY SHE HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
AND ACR.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA
US BILL IS PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
BUT WITH THAT WELCOME HAPPY NEW
YEAR EVERYONE MISTER SUN ON THE
HAVE YOU BEGAN.
A NUMBER OF US ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE PRESENTING ANOTHER COMMITTEE
SO I WAS DISASTROUS TO TRY TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE TIME.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS
WE CHANGED IN A WAY THAT THAT
BROUGHT FORWARD A PRODUCT THAT
CAN THAT KEPT THAT.
PULL TAB CAPTURED.
THAT REALLY REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF THAT LITTER GOING OUT INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT HOW WE'VE PROVEN
WE CAN BAN PLASTIC BAGS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. MICROBEADS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT EVERY NUMBER OF
THINGS BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
IT'S TIME.
THAT WE WORK WITH A.
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
BOTTLES COME BACK TO THE
RECYCLERS THEY COME BACK WITH
THE CAPS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT OR IS IT ASKS.
THE INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THAT BY
TWENTY TWENTY. PRODUCTS ALL THE
CALIFORNIA SINGLE USE PLASTIC
BOTTLES WITH PRODUCT AND I WILL%
COME BACK WITH A MECHANISM THAT
ATTACHED THE CAPS
YOU'LL SEE THERE ARE. EXAMPLES
THAT ARE THAT ARE OUT THERE I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH.
THE ORGANIZATION.
THAT I THINK BEALL PLASTICS AND
THEY RUN A THE CONTEST EVERY
COUPLE OF YEARS IN THE LAST ONE
THAT THEY RAN REALLY LOOKED AT
IDEAS FOR TETHERING CAPS AND
CAME UP WITH. WAS PRETTY
INTERESTING IDEAS NOT AYE SIR
ONE OF THEM.
ALL OF THEM MAY NOT WORK SOME OF
THEM MIGHT WORK BUT IT'S LONG
PAST TIME THAT WE MOVE FOR WITH
THIS NOTION OF INSURING THAT WE
BRING BACK. THE BOTTLES AND THE
CAPS TOGETHER SO THAT THEY CAN
BE RECYCLED SO THAT THEY CAN BE
PULLED OUT OF OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND NOT BE THE THE SIGNIFICANT
DETRIMENT THEY ARE TO OUR
WILDLIFE IT'S OR BEACHES INTO
OUR. COASTAL AREAS.
TO OUR DOWNTOWNS TO OUR PARKS TO
OUR RIVERS AND STREAMS AND LAKES
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HERE AYE VOTES I HAVE WITH ME
TELLING ME BE FOR CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE. AND THE PRESIDENT
CEO OF CG ROXANNE LLC RONA AND
POPPY ARTS BUT IF YOU DON'T MIND
AND THEN I DO A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS JURORS FIRST
OF ALL WE HAVE A QUORUM MINOR
ROLE.
PICKET TERRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
GARCIA HERE.
ACOSTA HERE.
ALLEN.
CHAO.
EGGMAN.
FLORA HERE.
THE AMOUNT.
MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI STONE FAIR.
BUT SECONDLY CENTER HAVE A
QUORUM THERE WERE TWO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT WERE MADE
MEMBERS THE FIRST ONE IS THAT AB
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE. WHERE ICICI
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR?
AND ACR ONE THIRTY SEVEN BY
MISTER GARCIA IS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT WITH CONSENT.
SO MOVED TO HAVE A SECOND.
MOVE BY MR SOUND SECOND WHEN MR
CHOW.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE A VOTE
ON ACR ONE THIRTY SEVEN.
THE ACTION IS.
WITH THE CONCEPT RECOMMENDATION
TO PASS GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
ACOSTA AYE COST AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE CHOW. CHOW AYE EGGMAN
FLORA. FLORA AYE THE MOON. THE
MOON AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
STONE. BY STONE AYE.
THAT IS THAT WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME
PLEASE.
BUT ASSISTANCE TO REMIND THEIR
TWO MINUTES AND I AM TIGHTENING.
THANK YOU CHECK GARCIA AND
MEMBERS KELLY MAKE THE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT NONPROFIT GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY AS TETHER CAPS ARE A
SIMPLE AND CONVENIENT TECHNOLOGY
THAT IF IMPLEMENTED CAN HELP
COUNTER THE EVER INCREASING
THREAT OF PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
CALIFORNIANS CONSUMER ELEVEN AND
A HALF A BILLION PLASTIC BOTTLES
EVERY YEAR.
THE OPPOSITION WILL TELL YOU
THAT EIGHTY THREE TO EIGHTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF BOTTLES
RETURNED FOR RECYCLING COME BACK
WITH THEIR CAPS ON. AND SO THERE
ISN'T A PROBLEM.
THIS STATE OF FAILED TO
RECOGNIZE BOTH THE SHEER VOLUME
OF DATA BOTTLES CONSUMED IN THE
REALITY THAT NOT EVERY BOTTLE
SOLD GETS RECYCLED.
SPIKE CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
RECYCLING RATE AMONG ALL
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS INCLUDING
ALUMINUM AND GLASS WE KNOW THAT
ONLY THREE OUT OF EVERY FOUR
PLASTIC BOTTLES SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY GET RECYCLED
AT THEIR END OF LIFE.
IF WE ADD UP THE BOTTLE CAPS
THAT ARE MISSING WHEN THEIR
BOTTLE GETS RECYCLED AND THE
BOTTLE CAPS THAT DON'T GET
RECYCLED AT ALL WITH THEIR
BOTTLES.
WE SEE THAT AN AVERAGE OF NEARLY
FIVE BILLION BOTTLE CAPS
ARE ENTERING OUR ENVIRONMENT
EVERY YEAR WHERE THEY ARE OFTEN
MISTAKEN FOR FOOD BY MARINE
WILDLIFE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ONE OF THE
TOP THREE ITEMS FOUND IN ALL
LARGE SCALE CALIFORNIA BEACH
CLEANUPS BOTTLE CAPS CONTRIBUTOR
URBAN BLIGHT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
A TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AN RTC
REPORT FOUND THAT CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPALITIES WERE SPENDING
NEARLY HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR. CLEARING TRASH FROM
STREETS PARKS AND STORM DRAINS
THE CITY OF COMMERCE RANKED
SECOND HIGHEST SPENDING EIGHT
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. A MUNICIPAL
SPENDING ON LITTER CONTROL IS
ONLY RISING AS IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA ENACTED
REGULATIONS REQUIRING ALL
JURISDICTION.
STOP TRASH FLOWS THROUGH THE
STORM DRAIN SYSTEM BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO.
IN A LAST POINT RECYCLERS WANT
TO CAPTURE THE PLASTIC FROM CAPS
THOUGH THE TECHNOLOGY IN USE
TODAY AND THE BOTTLES I HAVE
BEFORE ME. REQUIRE NO ADDITIONAL
PLASTIC AND IN SOME CASES
ACTUALLY USE LESS PLASTIC THAN
TRADITIONAL CAPS.
RECYCLING EQUIPMENT IS ALREADY
DESIGNED TO HANDLE. THE BAND
LEFT BY TEMPER EVIDENCE
PROOF PACKAGING THAT BAND IS
MADE OFA DIFFERENT PLASTIC THEN
THE BOTTLE AND IT IS CURRENTLY
BEING SEPARATED. SO WITH
TETHERED CAP WOULD BE SEAMLESSLY
INTEGRATED INTO EXISTING
RECYCLING PROCESS THESE.
ENCLOSING A TETHER TAP IS A WIN
WIN SOLUTION FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT
FOR RECYCLERS AND FOR PERSONAL
CONVENIENCE AND IS THE ONLY
SOLUTION THAT WILL PREVENT A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF CAPS FROM
BECOMING PLATE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND PLASTIC
POLLUTION'S ENVIRONMENT I HEARD
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THINKING
NEXT WITNESS.
BUT.
TWO MINUTES
SO.
ITEMS IN THIS COMPANY AND WE
HAVE DONE EXACTLY WHAT THESE.
LADIES ASKING FOR WE DID THIS
YEARS AGO FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS FOUGHT WARS OF REASONS
THAT SHE EXPLAINED PLUS ONE. IT
MAKES SENSE IT MAKES FINALS
FINAL VOTE FINANCIAL SENSE
DOCTOR YOU DO THAT.
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS YOU TO GO WAS
A LIGHTER PT BUT THERE HAS WHAT.
SO FALLS A PRODUCER'S EYES OR SO
AN INCENTIVE
TO GOAL WAS A COP THAT STAYS.
WAYS ABOUT HER ON OZ BEING SAY
HAS BEEN SAID FALLS A RECYCLING
IS ABSOLUTELY NO ISSUES.
SECRETIVE GOOD THINK THIS IS
WHAT WE DID BECAUSE WE OR
SWEENEY CYCLING AND FOR US YOU
KNOW I THINK HE'S GOING TO RUN
FEET UP TO BE JUST ON THESE
BEING RECYCLED MAKES NO SENSE.
SORT IDEA WAS TO HAVE BOTH BEING
A CYCLE BEING REDUCED.
AND I THINK THERE IS NOTHING A
LONG WAYS PRESIDENT.
CAN YOU STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU'RE WITH MY NAME IS OR NOT
BUT YOU.
AND I'M WE SEE JOKES ON A LOVE
SCENE.
CONDOMS OF PRESIDENCY WILL AS
WELL AS A MANAGING PARTNER.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE.
AMIRI AM GORDON I'M WITH
UPSTREAM POLICY AND WE'RE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO.
MR PUPPY OWES REMARKS AND HE
HAS TOLD US THAT THE.
THEY ARE SAVING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC AND MONEY AT
THE SAME TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THE REST OF US TO
SEE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION THAT
IN CHURCH JUST MILAN FOOT TO OF
ICONS HILDA BAY AND SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND ALSO WE'VE BEEN
OFSC CLEAN WATER ACTION. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
PROCESS TO DO ME TO FOR THEM
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE UNFAIR THAT OF ON THE%
ON BEHALF OF US ONLY. A
CALIFORNIA RELIEF AS WELL AS OUT
IN CALIFORNIA OWNS FROM SUPPORT.
ANY MARIN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
LEAVE A PICKUP IN CONSERVATION
THAT VOTERS THINK.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION COALITION
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISERS WITH
JOYO TOO MUCH FOUNDATION ZERO
WASTE USA AND I'VE BEEN ASKED BY
UGLY DOLL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA AND MO WITH SHODDY ORDER
ENTRY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
LINDA ESCALANTE HERE ON BEHALF
OF OUR ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANALYSTS RIVERO HERE ON BEHALF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THINK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE US
OPPOSITION.
CAN WE PLEASE MAKE A LITTLE ROOM
FOR THEM AT THE TABLE.
TWO MINUTES LINK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FABRIC MCGEE WITH THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TODAY. ON THE
INDUSTRY IS CLEARLY NOT OPPOSED
TO THE USE OF A TETHERED CAP.
IN OUR PAST THAT.
AUTHOR HAS MENTIONED IN HIS
BEEN MENTION THAT WE'VE DONE IT
WITH OUR CANS WHEN THE
TECHNOLOGY WAS THERE AND
AVAILABLE WE MAKE OUR BOTTLE
BILLS ARE PT ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
RECYCLABLE SO IT'S NOT A SPACE
THAT WE ARE NOT. TRYING TO GET
TO THE CHALLENGES IS THAT THIS
BILL IS ESTABLISHES A DATE BY
WHICH OUR TECHNOLOGY WON'T GET
US THERE AND SO THAT'S MY MAINLY
THE REASONS FOR OPPOSITION. I'M
WE'VE CONTINUALLY TO SUPPORT A
FINANCIALLY A WIDE RANGE OF
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE WE ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF.
OF THE WASTE THAT IS COMING UP
ON OUR BEACHES AND THE LETTERING
BEFORE THE TECHNOLOGY GETS THERE
FRANCIS IN OCTOBER OF THIS LAST
YEAR YELTSIN CONSERVANCY
ANNOUNCED A NEW INITIATIVE. THAT
THEY WANTED TO RAISE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS PLASTICS IN OUR OCEANS
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES ARE PART OF
THAT COMMITMENT AND WHERE THEIR.
WE HAVE ALSO BEEN INVOLVED WITH
OCEAN CONSERVANCY AND THEY'VE
AND INDICATED THAT ALMOST HALF
OF THE.
PLASTIC THAT WE FIND COMES FROM
FIVE DEVELOPING ASIAN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OUTSIDE AB
THREE NINETEEN WOULD IMPOSE
UNWORKABLE.
pSIMPLY NOT THERE THEIR
PROTOTYPES THAT ARE THERE.
ART WOULDN'T ACCOMMODATE A
BOTTLE DEBTS THIS SIZE SO FOR
INSTANCE THE BILL SAYS ANYTHING
A LEADER.
SORRY HE.
AS OUR. ACCOMMODATE A BILL
THAT'S ANYTHING A LEADER OR
LESS.
THIS IS LESS THAN A LEADER
THIRTY TWO OUNCES BUT THAT THAT
CRYSTAL GEYSER EXAMPLE COULD NOT
ACCOMMODATE A WIDE MOUTH BOTTLE
SUCH AS THIS.
CARBONATED DRINKS AND HOT
FILTERING SWITCHES WHAT THE BILL
PROVIDES FOR STILL THERE IS NO
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW
TO PROVIDE FOR ATTENDED COPPER
TAP FOR THAT KIND OF THE ARM.
BEVERAGE AND SO THREE NINETEEN
IS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL BUT
THAT'S NOT THE REALITY OF THE
TYPE OF BEVERAGES THAT ARE
PRODUCED NOT ONLY IN OUR STATE
BUT WORLDWIDE.
.
CALIFORNIA PRICES A REAP A
LEADER IN RECYCLING PLASTICS AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT WE HAVE EIGHTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF THE BOTTLES
THAT COME BAGGED DO HAVE THEIR
CAPS ON. WE CONTINUALLY HAVE
THREE FOURTHS OF THOSE THAT COME
BACK ULTIMATELY INTO THE RECYCLE
STREAM SO THERE IS SOME WORK TO
BE DONE CLEARLY BUT WE. DON'T WE
CAN'T SOLVE THAT PROBLEM IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO DO
IT. TETHER TAPS GENERALLY IN
SOME OF THE PRODUCTS WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL PLASTIC WHICH
IS CONTRARY TOMORROW THE OVERALL
GOAL OF TRYING HAVE LESS INTO
OUR WAY STREET. AND SO UNTIL WE
FIND OUT WHETHER IF IT'S A
TETHER TAP LIKE ON THE GLEE.
CRYSTAL GEYSER CAP A CUSTOMER.
COULD STILL HAVE THE TOP RUBBING
AGAINST THEIR NOSE OR THEIR
MOUTH AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT
WOULD PREVENT THEM FROM SIMPLY
ON* THAT AND I STILL HAVING
THE SAME PROBLEM THAT WE STARTED
OFF WITH. SO WE HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO WORK IN THAT INDUSTRY IS NOT
LIKE WE'VE IGNORED THIS PROBLEM
AND WE DIE FOR YOUR OP NO VOTE
ON THIS BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY
SIMPLY AS AN.
IF.
MR TURN MEMBERS BOB BACK ON
BEHALF THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION OF CALIFORNIA.
NOT TO BE REDUNDANT FOR THE
VERY EXCELLENT TESTIMONY FROM I
AM I MISS PIGGY ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF THE BILL SO THE P. R.
C. C. IS DEDICATED TO. A
RECYCLING OF OF BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS OF MADE A P. EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE PUBLIC
BOTTLES AND THE CAPS.
THERE A NUMBER OF ISSUES A WITH
THIS MANDATED IT CERTAINLY IS
BEING A PREMATURE IN TERMS OF
ITS IMPACT ON A VERY WIDE RANGE
OF BEVERAGES. AND IS THE AB LAID
OUT A TALK ABOUT CARBONATION.
AND THE IMPACT ON THAT CAP THEY
BELIEVE THE TETHER IT COULD
INVOLVE PLASTICS THAT ARE NOT
COMPATIBLE WITH PT RECYCLING SO
CONCERNED ABOUTTHE IMPACT ON.
THE OTHER COSTS RECYCLING THE
BILLY TO OFFICIALLY RECYCLE A
WITH POTENTIAL CAMERA
CONTAMINATION ON UNKNOWN
TECHNOLOGY FOR AN UNKNOWN RANGE
OF PRODUCTS THAT WE THINK IT'S
PREMATURE.
IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT THAT UP
VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
CONTAINERS ARE COMING BACK WITH
A CAPS
A FIXED.
WE SURELY WOULD ENCOURAGE
GREATER PUBLIC OUTREACH TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO DO JUST
THAT.
AND THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
ADDRESS A A LARGER PORTION
PROBLEM.
SHARE THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
LITTER AND INAPPROPRIATE A
DISPOSAL BUT AND WE HAVE TO.
DISCUSS THE IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF OF MANUFACTURERS TO
PRODUCE THIS PRODUCT.
WITH THE TETHER CAP OF THE
VARIETY OF PRODUCTS THE COST TO
DO SO WHEN THE TIMING FOR IT SO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
BEFORE WE GO MEMBER COMMENTS
THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S ALL BEYOND WE HAVE A
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS A WE
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU AS OUR MINOR JUST NAME
AN ORGANIZATION AND A POST.
THIRTY YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY MOSLEM HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER COMMERCE OPPOSITION.
SHE THE BROWN CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
THERE THOMAS WITH LITIGANTS
JOHNSON ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BAR WATER SUSPICION
IN THE INTERNATIONAL BOTTLED
WATER ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
THANKS.
OKAY THANK YOU I ANY. QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
MR. ON CAN I ASK THE PROPONENTS
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF.
TECHNOLOGY OR LACK THEREOF.
WELL I THINK THAT'S.
THAT THERE IS A GROWING.
NUMBER OF IDEAS TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE COMING FORWARD THAT I
THINK WILL SOLVE THAT THEIR
PROBLEM.
I HAD MET WITH THE INDUSTRY WHEN
WE INTRODUCED THIS BILL LAST
YEAR AND THEY WERE IN FACT
ASKING FOR TIME LINES. I HAVE
NOT HEARD FROM THEM WHAT AT WHAT
A REALISTIC TIME I WOULD BE AND
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO TO TALK
TO THEM ABOUT THAT WE WE PUT A
STAKE IN THE GROUND. HAS OF
TWENTY TWENTY TO REALLY TRY AND
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. IF THEY'RE
CLOSE IF THEY NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME I THINK THAT'S FINE
BUT YOU WE'VE SEEN SOME
EXAMPLES.
WHERE OTHERS HAVE COME UP WITH
THAT OR NOT INDUSTRY HAVE COME
UP WITH SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
TETHERED THAT USE LESS PLASTIC
WERE PRETTY MUCH THE SAME FORM?
OF OF CAP AS OTHERS THAT ARE
VERY LIKELY TO BE OF THE THROUGH
THE EXISTING SHIRI THAT IS OUT
THERE MEAN THESE MACHINES ARE
TURNING OVER PRODUCTS. ZILLIONS
OF PRODUCTS IN EVERY DAY.
AND SO A A GOOD SOLUTION WOULD
NEED TO WORK WITH OBVIOUSLY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE.
AND IF THERE ARE GOOD IDEAS THAT
ARE COMING FROM PLACES THAT ARE
NOT WELL FUNDED THEY DON'T HAVE
MUCH INCENTIVE OTHER THAN THAT A
REDUCTION I THINK THE INDUSTRY
CERTAINLY. CAN MOVE TO BE ABLE
TO FIT HER TO TAKE ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS OR COME UP WITH ONE OF
THEIR OWN. SO I'D I DISPUTE THAT
THERE IS NO TECHNOLOGY.
I THINK THE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
THERE OR ARE CLOSE AND THEIR
ENOUGH EXAMPLES TO BE ABLE TO
DRAW FROM TO BEN PUT THIS
PROCESS ON A REALISTIC TIME LINE
AND GET US. THE BOTTLE CAPS TO
OTHER. I UNDERSTAND IT WAS A
BILL SIMILAR BILL INTRODUCED IN
A TWO THOUSAND NINE THEREABOUTS.
R. AB NINE TWENTY FIVE SO. R..
THE BILL WAS HOLDING THE SENATE
THOUGH WHAT WAS THE REASON WAS
IT BECAUSE OF A TECHNOLOGY OR
LACK THEREOF AS WELL THAT. I AM
NOT SURE WHY THAT WAS HELD IN
THE SENATE THERE ALSO HAS BEEN
IF YOU GO BACK FAR ENOUGH.
SOME OF THAT CAP MATERIAL WAS
NOT QUITE ROUTE IS RECYCLABLE AS
THE AS THE P. ET.
THEY. THE BOTTLES THEMSELVES NOW
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT TRUE THEY
CAN CHOP UP THE PRODUCT IS A
COMES IN AND THE CAT MATERIAL
FLOATS SO THEY CAN BE SKIMMED
OFF. SO RECYCLERS ARE NOW
WANTING TO GET THE CAPS BACK
BECAUSE THAT'S RECYCLABLE
PRODUCT AS WELL SO THAT'S TAKEN
AWAY THAT THIS NOTION THAT THE
RECYCLERS DIDN'T REALLY WANT THE
CAPS THAT MIGHT HAVE HAD.
SOMETHING TO DO WITH.
WITH THE ISSUE THAT THAT BILL
HAD BACK THEN BUT THIS IS RIGHT
NOW.
THEIR CYCLES CAN CERTAINLY
HANDLE THE PRODUCT WANT THE
PRODUCT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
VALUABLE RECYCLABLE PRODUCT IN
WE SHOULD ENSURE THAT THE CAPS
ARE COMING BACK THE BOTS.
CAN I ALSO ASK THE OPPONENT JUST
ISSUE OFF OUT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
AS FAR AS TIME FRAME IS
CONCERNED WINDY EXPECTS THAT GO
TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE. AVAIL
GRATEFUL.
MR SHALL ALL THE COMPANIES ARE
INDEPENDENTLY WORKING ON IT
THEIR FEARS COMPARED PET
COMPETITORS IN THE MARKETPLACE
SO IT IS JUST BECAUSE EVERYONE
ON THE OUTSIDE DOESN'T SEE A
SAMPLING IT. THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT IT'S NOT GOING ON AND THEY
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF TIMES WILL
HAVE A PROTOTYPE THAT MIGHT WORK
IT ORIGINALLY BUT AFTER IT'S
BEEN TESTED.
SHELF LIFE ONESELF WITH BALLS
OFF THE SHELF IN THOSE KIND OF
THINGS AND IT DOESN'T HAVE THE
UMPS SAFETY REQUIREMENTS AT THE
FDA REQUIRES OF US SO THE LONG
TERM EVEN IF WE HAD A PROTOTYPE
FOR FRANCE'S COCA COLA. ARE
BIGGER PRODUCER IF WE HAD A
PROTOTYPE THAT WAS READY TO GO
RIGHT NOW TO GET IT IN ALL THEIR
PRODUCTION STRAINED IT WOULD
TAKE EIGHT TO TEN YEARS FOR THEM
TO GET OUT THERE AND HAVE IT ON
THE SHELF. AND THAT'S IF YOU
HAVE ONE THAT'S HOT FEEL RECALL
FILLED TO BE ABLE TO TEST IT OUT
BECAUSE IT WON'T ALWAYS WORK THE
FIRST TIME YOU DO IT YOU HAVE TO
GO BACK. INTEMPERATE IN THAT'S
THE TIMEFRAME THEY PROVIDED FOR
ME EIGHT EIGHT TO TEN YEARS
THAT'S GOVERNMENT PROVIDING.
THE WORK WILL GO TO MISTER FLOOR
ON YOUR.
I GOT MORE THAN THE GODDESSES.
REITERATE.
AS FAR AS THE INDUSTRY'S
PERSPECTIVE WHAT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE TIMEFRAME TO GET THIS
DONE AND IF YOU.
THE AUTHORED MENTIONED YOU KNOW
OF AN ACCEPTABLE TIME FOR WHAT
WOULD THAT BE FOR YOU FOLKS.
THE PROBLEM IS A MISTER FOR IS
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
NOW RIGHT SO WE DON'T HAVE A
PROTOTYPE THAT HAS NOW. BEEN.
SHOWN TO WORK ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE TIME BEEN
RELIABLE HAVE THE TAMPER
RESISTANT.
PROTECTIONS THAT WE NORMALLY
NEED FOR OUR PRODUCTS AND SO.
IT IS HARD TO SAY YOU KNOW HARD
CORE WE CAN DO THIS IN X. EUROPE
WE HAD A PROTOTYPE IN ONLY
QUESTION WOULD BE CHANGING OVER
MACHINERY OR DOING THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS THAT WE COULD GIVE YOU A
HARD DAY. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
SOMETHING AND THEN EVEN IF YOU
HAVE ONE PROTOTYPE THAT'S
AVAILABLE JUST WHAT'S JUST FOR
ARGUMENT'S SAKE SAY THAT THAT
EXISTS. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVING POLICY
THAT ONLY BENEFITS ONE COMPANY
AND THAT IS NOT USUALLY A PLACE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE LIKE SERBIA
WHERE YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING A
WINDFALL FOR ONE COMPANY THAT
EVERYONE OUT OF ALL THE BUT THE
BEVERAGES THAT WE PRODUCE IN THE
STATE. WOULD HAVE TO GO TO ONE
COMPANY TO PRODUCE IT'S TOPS AND
THAT JUST IS NOT A SPLIT GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY IN THAT SPACE.
AND THERE IS NO.
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN SMALLER
COMPANIES A LOT OF THESE ETHNIC
DRINKS THAT YOU SEE IN SOME OF
SMALLER SUPERMARKETS IN THE
LARGER CUP THERE'S NO.
THEY'RE NOT EXEMPT FROM THIS
BILL CORRECT THEY'RE NOT AND SO
IF YOU HAVE A PRODUCT THAT MAY
BE AN ASIAN PRODUCT OR SOMEONE
SOMETHING FROM ONE OF OUR LATIN
COUNTRIES.
IF THEY CANNOT COME INTO THE
STATE WOULD BE ABLE BE ABLE TO
BE SOLD AND SOME ARE SMALL
ETHNIC STORES ON BECAUSE THEY
WOULDN'T COMPLY WITH THAT WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
MS EGGMAN. ONE.
THINK YOU AND I AM I APOLOGIZE
MISTER STONE THAT I. CAN GET TO
HEAR ALL THE TESTIMONY.
AND I CAN I THINK YOU'RE JUST
FIGURE BECAUSE THIS IS THE
PROTOTYPE RIGHT I MEAN THIS IS
THIS IS NOT A PROTOTYPE IT'S.
READY TO GO. CORRECT DOWN.
.
IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU
ARE ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND WILLING TO DEVELOP
APPROPRIATE TIME LINES IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THIS.
M..
I I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE.
WHEN ONE PLASTIC NOWHERE TO
WHAT TIME OF PLASTIC BAGS RIGHT
AND I BY REPRESENT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA GONNA.
A PAPER PLANT AND WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE GOES DOWN ON WE CHARGE
FOR IT AND AS A DATA
REPRESENTATIVE I DID VOTE FOR
THAT.
BUT WHEN I WAS A VOTER WHEN HE
CAME ON THE BALLOT I DID. AND I
HAVE SEEN A TREMENDOUS DECREASE
THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC BAGS
FLYING AROUND I THINK WE ALL
HAVE RIGHT IT WAS A BIG LEGO WE
CAN IMAGINE. AND WE'VE SEEN A
TREMENDOUS DECREASE.
IS OVER THIS WEEK AND I KNEW
THIS WAS COMING UP SO I JUST YOU
KNOW.
WRITTEN BY A REDCAR START LOOK
AND YOU SEE THE CAPS EVERYWHERE
ON THE GROUND STEP UNAMIR YOUR
TOE EVERYWHERE ANYWAY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT. YOU GET ALL
THE WAY ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
THIS YEAR.
BUT I CERTAIN WILL BE SUPPORTING
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND LOOK
FORWARD YOU CONTINUE TO DO THE
WORK SO WE CAN COME UP SOME REAL
WORKABLE SOLUTIONS.
AFTER CALIFORNIA THINK.
US.
TOMORROW BUT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBERS THIS IS A
REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE A STAND ON LETTER BOTTLE
CAPS REGARDLESS OF THE
STATISTICS ARE STILL. ONE OF THE
TOP TEN THIRD FIFTH DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU COUNTED ITEMS THAT ARE
FOUND IN BEACH CLEANUPS RIVER
CLEAN UP SOME PARK CLEANUPS IF
YOU START LOOKING AROUND NOW
YOU'LL SEE HOW UBIQUITOUS THEY
ARE. BECAUSE THEY DON'T END UP
GOING BACK WITH THE BOTTLES.
IF WE PUSH POLICY TO ENSURE THAT
THE CAPS ARE CONTAINED OR ATTACH
REASONABLY TO A BOTTLE SO THAT
THERE'S A CHANCE FOR TO COME
BACK AND. GIVE THE INDUSTRY THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO COME UP WITH
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF A NUDGE A
SPUR GET THEM TO TO COME UP WITH
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION WE CAN
SOLVE A BIG PROBLEM FOR
CALIFORNIA. WHEN UP ANY PRODUCT
WERE NOT TURNING A PRODUCT AWAY
WE'RE TRYING TO SAY LET WORK
WITH US LET'S CREATE A PRODUCT
THAT FITS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES.
THAT STANDS UP WE ALREADY HAVE
ONE COMPANY HERE THAT THAT
THINKS THIS IS A GREAT IDEA
THEIR LARGE DISTRIBUTOR ACROSS
THE STATE THEY'RE. THEY'RE DOING
THIS ON THEIR OWN.
THEY'RE DOING IT I THINK IN IN
OUR MARKET IN OTHERS PROBABLY
WITH WITH MULTIPLE PRODUCTS SO
THE TECHNOLOGY IS REALLY THERE
OR ITS NASCENT AND IT IS COMING
IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE ON THE
FOREFRONT. AND ENSURE THAT
BOTTLE CAPS OR ATTACH THE
BOTTLES AND WE HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO REMOVE
THIS OFFENDING PLASTIC FROM OUR
ENVIRONMENT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT. TO THE
BILL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST.
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NOW ALLEN. ALLEN NO CHAO.
CHAO AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FLORA.
FLORA NO THE MOAN.
THE MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
STONE BY STONE AYE.
PUT BILLS OUT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP IT OPEN
FOR A FEW ABSENT MEMBER
SOMETHING CHAIR.
FIVE. BESIDE OUT I'M SORRY IT'S
NOT OUT.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR COMPANY
AB THREE NINETEEN GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE.
THAT BILL HAS THE BOTH WITH ME
I'M GONNA KEEP DEVELOPER FOR A
COUPLE MORE MINUTES FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THINK.
WE'RE TALKING.
YEAH.
THAT
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE AGAIN FOR
MAYBE THREE NINETEEN. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
AND NEXT A YES OUT AND THEN THE
FOOD WAS THE RECORDING IS SET TO
CONSENT.
ACR WHEN THIRTY SEVEN PARTY.
BOTH ARE OUT I WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN SESSION THANK YOU